this is different there are protests in
China but not like this
happen they're local maybe a
demonstration over pensions at a plant
or pollution these protests are National
we have a sense now that people have the
same grievance against the regime and
that's new
over China's drastic zero covet policy
turned first to frustration and now to
anger where most of the world has moved
on from lockdowns they're still as rigid
as ever for the Chinese one person
contracts covet in an apartment the
whole building can be confined the
nightmare stories have been growing for
months from suicides to deaths in a bust
that overturned caring people to
quarantine
[Music]
latest story is a fire last week 10
people were killed and the lockdown is
being blamed the reports people couldn't
get out quickly enough because they were
confined and reports firefighters were
delayed by lockdown fencing it's hard to
know if either is true people identify
with the victims the fire that happened
in ulanchi in the westernmost part of
the country is resonated with people who
live in Shanghai at the other end
the Chinese government Monday called the
reports about the fire disinformation
smears spread on social media
now traditional media in China is
tightly controlled there are no mentions
of the protests word has gotten out on
social media posts are deleted by the
government if they're about the protests
but that takes time if they're up even
for minutes they can be seen
proof that has happened is in a symbol
that's being spread blank sheets of
paper now represent Defiance in cities
across the country and with Chinese
artists outside the country some
analysts say the government can't let
this go on for long oh it's highly
dangerous I think we haven't really seen
the repressive apparatus fully engaged
at this point but unfortunately I I
think that is what we're going to
observe in the days and weeks to come
covid rules maybe the biggest part of
what's going on but there are also some
openly criticizing the Communist party
and leader Xi Jinping
now the government could let some of the
pressure out by relaxing coveted rules
but China has an aging population low
vaccination rates and a less effective
domestic vaccine opening up would mean
other problems
Mike Armstrong Global News